hello welcome to three scary games in
exactly 33 seconds there will be a jump
scare I'm telling you this so you can
mentally prepare yourself for it however
at 13 minutes and 33 seconds there will
be another jump scare you might forget
about that one try not to and at 23
minutes and 33 seconds there will be a
third jump scare so far away that as
you're watching this video you'll think
in your subconscious that there's
something amiss something you've
forgotten something you've neglected to
remember something that you think you
ought to be aware of and then alright
this is dementia I'm guessing it's a
game about dementia if I had to guess
oh god hello ah Mouse is a little
sensitive god I can't change it alright
I'll deal with it
hello I don't have a lot of lights in my
apartment don't pay my electrical be
high hmm interesting
hello how are you doing good nice to
meet you oh hello hi how are you doing
good to see you okay well I certainly
don't remember living in this place like
the implication that I need to run but
I'm gonna anyway crouch okay crotch is a
little funky there we go
well alright oh oh why am i breathing
what what why would I why what press f2
turn on the flashlight oh I really love
that I can only see that through my
phone I really love that and by love I
mean hate I hate it so much I hate that
oh no oh no oh no oh my god it's not the
first time
okay it's not the first time I've ever
seen this mechanic but more whiskey to
hide the mobile phone why would I want
to do that is the question why would it
why would one such as me wish to do such
a thing
hello hi oh did you see that did you see
that on the phone oh that was weird
Oh No hey hey I did whoa wait whoa why
are we glowing oh hi hey dude hey nice
light I can do that too I can flick your
lights you're not special you think
you're special you're not I didn't know
I had a theater room with a full
projector what no what oh that was just
a tutorial oh that was just the tutorial
for that better than just the tutorial
wait
have I been here before is that part of
the experience oh how are we are we good
you good bro oh well that's not fun
I like the other pictures better okay
[ __ ] towns night terror last night
turned to crimson red is the Chicago PD
uncovered a gruesome crime scene which
evidence points to have been the site of
mysterious mass disappearance of at
least 12 young women all of which
coincidentally lived in the Jay Matthews
University residence a forensic analysis
revealed that the girls all between ages
of 19 to 22 suffered a variety of
gruesome deaths but all of them happened
within the span of three and a half
minutes even these facts the
investigators have proposed the cause to
be a collective suicide
the truth remains to be unclear ah you
know some tells me something something
my gut tells me that worked suicide
something tells me it might may have
been murder Mui de righty-ho then
peekaboo how are you oh sure yeah all
right that's fine I was gonna look at
that anyway you didn't need to tell me
about it
but I'll dignify it I read this I
already read that what you think I
didn't read it walls with invisible ink
you rat bastard my beautiful walls don't
like that none what happens if I deviate
from the path how badly will I be
horribly murdered if I deviate from the
path
I don't even know if anything bad will
happen if I deviate from the half
probably nothing bad will happen
probably fine I should try it here I go
I felt very Max Payne you just got it
you fall it's the thing you you fall you
fall off and you die that's what happens
anybody remember that from Max Payne
okay here we go
woody what wait that's different what
it's different dude dude it's different
I didn't even notice I was too busy
Lonnie dying hi hey how are you doing it
I'm blood I'm not blind hello I don't
know the phone anymore Oh a deadiy bear
in the dark I don't understand why this
is here it doesn't look damaged or dirty
maybe it's related to the investigation
maybe it's related to me oh good I'm
back here I wanted well I have that now
that's in my mind Palace that's what
this is it's my mind memory palace oh
that's not a dark empty void somehow I
would rather have the dark empty void
hello someone here speak up if you'd
like to murder me shut up go away I
don't want to talk to you I don't want
to do anything to you I don't want to
even I should've ducked in the room
maybe I should have maybe abduct in the
room I should have maybe have gone in
the room my back spin off to the teddy
bear over there yeah and it's definitely
a teddy bear all right now definitely I
investigated it and it's for certainly
okay you're there yeah and you're
charging down the hall no thank you
close the door that'd be a good idea
well it's a bit much sorry I'm my part I
didn't mean to scream that loud quite a
visceral reaction and I don't know why
I'm fine by the way
anybody ever asked me if I'm fine after
something like that happens no I usually
charging you charging you I'm charging
you I'm running away from you do not do
anything to me go away go away go away
put away the phone you can't get me
maybe I'm gonna run a circle around not
try the circle method or a circle round
circle a cycle I'll run a circle around
him okay well that's not oh that's not
what I thought it was gonna be that's
not what I thought it was gonna be this
different than what I thought it was
previously going to be it's different
yeah the weird thing is that it's
different it's different it's different
did I see something in front of me just
then something towards the door
something black and white my memory is
telling me that there was something was
it just the flicker of that it might
have just been the light here there I am
unsure oh I can't close the door well
then why didn't it work before well eat
my ass you did what you could
I don't think I did anything and I I
don't think I did anything and I I don't
like the accusation that I have done
anything because I haven't okay I guess
I'm running away now I guess this is
what I probably should be doing yeah I
pity you pity oh you look stupid II I
look stupid II there's nothing behind me
all right sure yeah
sure sure that's not what you that we
didn't agree on that we didn't agree on
that at all all right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you think that you know
what you do not know you think you know
and yet the truth of the matter is that
you do not know whoa oh no it's Bobby I
know I knew it so I'm very squeaky today
it's fine
all good in this neighborhood this
neighborhood it's all good baby
how you doing Oh nice touch huh
can I have that I can't I cannot have
that the answer is I can't have that
that right there can't have it would
never be able to have that I got it sure
sure I got an old key good for me
anybody gonna pop out at me all right
whatever you say eyes a nightmare over
good
oh no wait a minute now I don't like
well I'm Bund around I'm blind the
bodies are gone
Oh painting a photo of a family for some
reason I can't really see the people in
it but the shape seemed very familiar to
me
this is family somehow related to the
case I'm thinking that there ain't no
case I'm thinking what the situation is
is that there actually is no case and
this is actually a circumstance in which
I don't really know what's true or not
yeah hey who threw the painting on the
ground who would do such a thing I'm
running I get it I'm running I get it I
get it I understand that I'm not even
bothering with that why would anybody
bother with that not me I'm not gonna
bother with that well I ain't got time
I'm running there's the thing I'm up I'm
out of run
please don't whoa what you should stop
uh oh no I should not stop as a thing
the funny thing about it is actually I
should not the thing is I shouldn't stop
because you know that his problem finds
the problem his problem problem problem
problem problem problem
all right good solution all right cool
what a lovely office what a perfectly
quaint office what a delightfully
delectable office this good office I
know a good office when I see it this is
one of them good ones mmm good one
lieutenant Duggan lieutenant Dugan
lieutenant do Goodin Oh Damien priest
Damien the Twilight Lord
ah this always goes this way it always
does it's it's a game that I'm really
into that's a lot of potential I'm super
down with the mechanics it's kind of
spooky and yet at the end of day it's
just a demo
oh so unfortunate Oh anyway here are the
credits there they go dad this was good
I like the concept of pretty spooky I
mean I feel like the mechanics need to
be expanded upon but it was nice and
setting up some nice moments and
surprises some panics getting around an
obstacle it was good it was really good
not perfect but so anyway moving on well
someone is T posing in the back there Oh
twitchy twitchy right this is a dead
scape demo which I imagine means said
I'm gonna get into it just long enough
and then it's gonna pull the rug out
from under my feet at the very last
second and I'm not gonna be able to get
a satisfying ending however I'm going to
risk that because it seems interesting
even if it is just a running in the
sewer tag game alright
hey how you doing hey what's up
objective get out all right I don't know
if my teensy tiny brain can handle that
many instructions all at once
peekaboo I see you
interesting seems as though there might
be something lurking in the darkness
here this does remind me of Jubilee
what's it what's the name lick scene
what's the name of the game they'd the
sewer game with the people the game that
I beat the one that I definitely beat
ooh what was the name of that nemesis
was it nemesis no that doesn't sound
right
nemesis was it nemesis maybe I should
keep moving
focus on what's happening in front of me
hi well that sounds good it's just the
way out can I get out no no damn it they
built the ladder in the middle of the
hole instead of at the side I can't
squeeze my thick ass through that no way
in hell I know it's a sewer so I'm not
gonna question why it's so goopy why is
it so loud so loud in this sewer so loud
yeah yeah this place smells like [ __ ]
it's really loud something's gonna pop
out of me
I can tell hello-o
don't like that what am I seeing what am
i seeing a door oh nice dick hi oh wait
no my object permanence may not be that
good but I'm pretty sure what I was
seeing at the end of this hallway was
not that okay sure sure
looks like I'm lost yeah what about that
thing at the end of the hallway what
what was what was what you wanted you
want to talk to me about that you wanted
you wanna give me a rundown at what
maybe that was all about you want to
maybe give me a little bit of a Oh No
dead end
I know you're gonna have something about
that at me I know you're gonna do it
don't think I guess that's fine hi what
des whew yeah my questioning all right
cool
just gonna ignore it you know there's
nothing to that oh good it's a dead end
all right cool good I like the dramatic
timing but clad nothing happened hello
okay there's a light down there and
nothing down here Oh take that light
stupid idiot ah I'm too much of a genius
to be beaten by the likes of you light
oh hello
uh-huh hi where am I
did I go in a big-ass circle Oh No I've
got to find a way out of here yeah
that's what I've been trying to do buddy
I've really been trying to do that kind
of difficult don't know which way I'm
going
freaking a hey hey hey hey stop that
douche holes I don't know who did that
what did I just see shadows I think just
shadows and shapes
speaking of shadows and shape there's
something at the end they're not sure
what that's about
looks a little bloody oh hey nice ass
are you doing there hey what's up what
are you
[Music]
okay I turned off the music in my
headphones for that holy [ __ ] it's May
25th actually right today so where's
this full version a body was found in
the sewers of Bakersfield California the
unknown victim was completely mutilated
nothing but mush he also had possessions
of drugs dropping the case with the
sighting of monsters so we're told how
would you know he had possession of
drugs if it was just mush all right well
then rough around the edges I will say
that but it did like scare me once or
twice which I could do you know that
kudos for that but over overall could
use some polish wink wink wink but not
bad
it's still pretty good III appreciate
for what it is moving on this game is
called don't do it Wow hi Cerberus that
server are you sir B sir Bieber B all
right cool ah I got hired as a New
Scientist three months ago and was
placed in the genetic engineering team
it's always good genetic engineering is
always a good start to a horror game we
have restricted access to certain areas
in the building
tom said we'd lose more than our jobs if
we were too curious but how can I not be
when I sometimes hear strange noises you
know I I hear strange noises all the
time and my instinct is not to go see
what it is once when I worked late at
night I saw a crowd of people being led
down stairs on I never saw them again I
brought it up to my lab manager and he
said not to worry about it this all
checks out it was all good I don't think
it was a good idea to tell him I wonder
what the research lab is brewing yeah
you told them their Fleur that probably
keeping an eye on you and therefore you
probably shouldn't do anything out of
the ordinary where am I there's
something in my bag oh happy this day
309 oh mrs. dr. wen director of Jay N
squared by weaponry research well we
went history today specimens number 21
sir mind it is a beauty a deadly one
we will continue to monitor its behavior
in the observatory Oh
oh god hunkajunk Dhaka Lanka clunk oh I
didn't want one actually be open no I
didn't want this I actually did not want
this the thing about it is I I need
doctor means actually don't know how to
pronounce that I know it's a very common
name but I for six number two someone
was curious and press the button last
night while I was away because it opened
a barn door of the observatory well
maybe you shouldn't have a button that
does the button to the death door maybe
the death door should have more than one
button do it you ever think about that
why is a curiosity button got in and
half your staff dying alright anyway I'm
curious man I'm really curious I'm gonna
go down farther big abou frickin frackin
frak me I'm fine we're all good let's
yeah we're all good it's all good yeah
it's good baby good baby it's good it's
good it's good thing that's good thing
oh oh thank you a cutie Oh ain't you
blessed cutie oh god you're the worst
today is it a greatest discovery to
other members of our secret organization
everyone is excited the world favours
chaos over peace my name will be written
down in history as the Creator on
[Applause]
that's a nice identification drawing
right there licks and zoom in on that oh
man hey it's you you put some strike
Iran that it looks just like you know
your arts better no that's not what I'm
saying
I'm not saying your art no it's just you
I mean you're
you can see the resemblance take your
hair off take it off
see I'm sorry I'm sorry anyway I got a
key card don't know why it sounded like
someone breathing in my ear when I
picked it up what is going on here what
what am I looking at what am I looking
at why do I hate it why someone dripping
spit into my ear okay well this is this
is a mountain this is my favorite TV
show love it love it I love it oh it's
dark in here
you know we could not do things like
that and you know life would carry on
just the same oh you're dead okay don't
don't push the button that'll end
people's lives just don't do it
they 377 walk number for food supplies
running room we have been under
suspicion for how large holders it is
time to move to plan B okay our Plan B's
Plan B involves feeding some kind of
people to some kind of thing is that
what I'm picking up am i picking up what
you're putting down my raking in what
you're spreading around am I getting it
I think I'm getting it I think I might
be getting it all right hey whoa don't
pray you know what yeah I'm not gonna
I've learned my lesson okay this glass
in between I'll kick good oh well I
suspected it greatly that that would
happen I was actually pretty almost
hundred percent positive
okay skipping ahead okay so just for the
record you know I'm not a fan of games
that start you from the beginning when
you die however it was not that far so I
will forgive it just this once or never
account also I am going to find out what
this button do
[Music]
well I'm sure that was good oh hi
that's different that's different that's
very different
oh I let it out oh I bet I let it out
ooh that's what I was looking at that's
why you were just standing there because
you weren't standing there because
you're dead and you're on a meat hook ha
the mystery all falls into place
oh you were here for a while and then
you died what a cool story
oh that's the direction that it went out
of great oh good oh good
oh God egads
gadzooks alright so that that's it just
out now why did I want that to happen
why did I need that desert was there
anything in here that I needed there was
I picked up nothing in here oh oh one
five eight nine six is the code one five
eight nine six it's [ __ ] time I'm I
was gonna like make a gun for it but I
don't want to make a gun for it okay so
what I need to do is I need to slip me
sloop rap bandits - Cassie wuss
oh there's Toki see one five eight nine
six easy pose easily easiest for ZZ I've
ever preceded one five eight nine six
I'm out of here
no mumbo jumbo go jumbo mumble oh we're
fine
[Applause]
evacuate evacuate evacuate i evacuated
my bowels hey oh let's go hey
oh no no hey ho ladies and gentlemen I
am proud to present to you an army of
two luminous I love her and I will
protect two Lumi til the end of my days
if they don't eat me
all right well two luminous is really
cute so the answer to this question is
to not do it I like that no it's good
it's short sweet to the point kind of
spooky that was good stuff liked it good
so thank you everybody so much for
watching that was three scary games
did you see the scares coming I don't
know where we are right now in the
timeline but maybe there's a scare just
waiting around the corner maybe this
video will end before it gets here
who knows or maybe the scares will
happen in a less predictable pattern
than you think if you want to see more
scary games they're linked in the
description below or in the suggested
videos down there click them watch them
enjoy them thanks again for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]